c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie
téléchargez l'appli jeter gris et tente
de remporter jusqu'à un million d'euros
sans rien faire bravo l'auto facile
d'être riche
terry cap ou pas cap de te faire un
sourcil comme adil rami avec cette
petite tour de l'ipad il alors ça va dit
je le verse est aussi là alors tu as
bien une source sûre ce n'est déjà fait
des concerts on a l'impression que tu
sais on se trompe on y va il est où le
stylet ou le sourcing et des faits le
moi ma chérie et papa de son fils déjà
c'est vrai mais le fait le forcing mais
c'est pas avait fait comme seul sans
voix dit lastours élastomère valon
behrami ah non mais bien faire on aurait
pu le faire bien d'animation patois ses
idées
[Applaudissements]
je ne l'étais faire ça m'a dit tu me lis
je suis prêt dans le pee wee de diam's
et vitaa et le fait bien et on s'est
trop l'a annoncé
[Musique]